good morning John speaking of abject
nihilistic despair as you did in your
last video I want to talk about a a
milestone that we are approaching in the
United States of America sometime in
2019 the FTC is predicting that there
will be more mobile phone calls
attempting to defraud people then there
will be mobile phone calls not
attempting to defraud people there will
be more robo calls van calls I'm
visiting my in-laws in Florida right now
it's beautiful I've had five slices of
key lime pie in the last five days and
they have a landline in their house like
a physical cable that plugs into a wall
that connects to other cables all over
the literal world the engineering
necessary to make this happen and also
the fact that like five or ten years ago
it would seem completely normal to me
and now it seems both like
extraordinarily inefficient and also
kind of adorable is really interesting
that's not what I'm here to talk about
there phone it rings a lot to get maybe
seven phone calls a day three or four of
them are from people who are trying to
steal there none here are a few of the
stories my mother-in-law has heard one
the IRS is going to arrest you tomorrow
have you've all heard that one but
here's better while your grandson has
been arrested in Africa and he needs
bail money free the radio station has
three CDs four E and four she has
inherited money five Microsoft is
updating windows and in order to
maintain your connection to the internet
you have to buy this $50 software
package they look at a part of Florida
where the average age is higher than
normal and these scams are somewhat
targeted at the elderly one because they
tend to have money in retirement
accounts and two because on average they
are a little less likely to have kept up
on how things work so I'll create a say
are you literally a robocall you're
literally a robocall no I'm making a
video right now 2017 3% of mobile phone
calls were from fraudulent sources in
2018 it was up to 30% the FTC estimates
that for every successful fraud the
scammer gets about $400 and that in
total over a billion dollars has been
stolen I tweeted about a year ago that
like any legislator who wants to just
get elected in any election ever should
do something about this because
obviously it's something that
everyone agrees should get fix and I
assume that may be the reason why it
hadn't gotten fixed was like money in
politics or telecom companies being evil
or just general in capability of doing
anything in Washington but no actually
it turns out that these people are good
at hiding from the law and that
technology allows them to do that for
the most part there may be a bit of this
that telecom companies could do
something about if they wanted to work
harder on it in any case it's a lot more
complicated than I thought it was if you
want to learn more about why it's
complicated I've linked to some articles
in the description basically
technologies are integrating together
that weren't meant to integrate together
people are sometimes bad people and I
don't think that when we created this
system we understood the significance we
were putting into the institution of the
phone number it is of course disgusting
in like 20 different ways a thing that I
didn't think about though was that for a
lot of people like the majority of the
times that the world reaches out to them
in any given day are people trying to
steal their money and that's a pretty
big societal cost one more way in which
a lot of people have just lost faith in
the world around them likely all because
of just a few hundred or maybe a
thousand operating scammers in the u.s.
it's really not much more than that in
shortage on human existence is messy and
culture technology and crime all
interact and weird and unexpected ways
as well I'm a pretty optimistic and pro
human person if you like allow 1,000
people out of 300 million to ruin
something by being bad people and making
money at it yeah I'm not that optimistic
like that will happen but I do think
it's important to remember that a lot of
people talk to scammers more than they
talk to people and so when I get a
chance to talk to people I'm gonna do my
best to be nice to them John I'll see
you on Tuesday